[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Sirin guten Abend ihnen allen
Formel 1 und Bundesliga Nachschlag
später Sport mit Katja unter anderem
genau schönen guten Abend hier sind
unsere sonntagsthemen
Katastrophe im Stadion nach einem
Fußballspiel in Indonesien stürmen
wütende Fans das Feld bei einer
Massenpanik sterben 125 Menschen
auf dem Vormarsch die Ukraine feiert die
Rückeroberung von Liman Deutschland will
in den nächsten Tagen ein
Luftabwehrsystem liefern
und Frust statt Titelparty Formel 1
Pilot für stappen verpasst die erste
Chance auf seine zweiten
Weltmeistertitel in Singapur siegt
Teamkollege Harris
[Musik]
ja nicht nur die Fußballwelt ist
erschüttert über das was da gestern
Nacht in einem indonesischen Stadion
geschah nach einem Spiel kommt es zu
Ausschreitungen und zu einer Massenpanik
mindestens 125 Menschen sterben etwa 300
werden verletzt Fragen wirft das
Vorgehen der Polizei auf über eine der
wohl schwersten stadionkatastrophen der
Geschichte jetzt Norman Odenthal
das Spiel ist vorbei das Drama beginnt
fensterheimerschaft Arima stürmen von
den Rängen auf den Rasen Wut über die
Niederlage soll das gewesen sein die
Situation ist komplett außer Kontrolle
aufgebrachte Fans rigorose Polizisten
eine Eskalation die sich später kaum
noch begreiflich erklären lässt
[Applaus]
die Fans wollten die Spieler zur Rede
stellen die Sicherheitskräfte mussten
einschreiten um das zu unterbinden dabei
haben sie Tränen Gas eingesetzt denn sie
wurden angegriffen die Situation war
gerade zu anarchisch die Polizei Feuer
Tränen Gas auf dem Rasen und das ist
besonders verhängnisvoll auch auf die
Ränge tausende Menschen wollen nur noch
weg auf ihrer Flucht werden viele
erdrückt sie ersticken
Opfer der Massenpanik
das Tränengas war überall viele meiner
Freunde haben ihr Leben verloren weil
die Polizisten unmenschlich mit uns
umgegangen sind es war schrecklich
für Gäste Fans aus Surabaya hatte es
keine Tickets gegeben aus
Sicherheitsgründen trotzdem war das
Stadion überfüllt 38.000 dürfen rein
42.000 waren da warum eine von vielen
Frauen
ich ordne anders vorerst keine Spiele in
der Liga ausgetragen werden erst müssen
die Untersuchungen abgeschlossen die
Sicherheit verbessert werden ich hoffe
das war die letzte Tragödie die sich im
indonesischen Fußballer ereignet hat
die Bilder vom Morgen danach sprechen
eine klare Sprache das war kein Sport
das war eine Schlacht eine Schlacht mit
vielen Opfern
ungewöhnlich direkt hat Papst franziskus
heute an den russischen Präsidenten
appelliert in Rom warb er eindringlich
für Frieden und bat Putin die Spirale
der Gewalt zu stoppen der Kremlchef ließ
heute die Heimatstadt des ukrainischen
Präsidenten angreifen wohl die Antwort
auf die jüngste militärische Niederlage
in der Ostukraine denen Kiew weitere
folgen lassen will Claudia Weiler
weg mit den russischen Flaggen nach rund
fünf Monaten Besatzung weht über dem
Verwaltungsgebäude von Liman wieder die
ukrainische Fahne
vollständig von den russischen
Streitkräften geräumt danke an unsere
Militärs unsere Krieger
schon nächste Woche so der Präsident
will die Armee weitere Orte
zurückerobern südöstlich von Liman nahe
der Front bereiten sie ihre Waffen vor
und hoffen auf Verstärkung
wir brauchen mehr Unterstützung von
unseren westlichen Verbündeten mehr
Munition mehr Waffen mehr Hilfe für
Gegenangriffe brauchen wir einfach mehr
Unterstützung
genau die hat Verteidigungsministerin
Lambrecht in Odessa versprochen schon in
wenigen Tagen werde Deutschland ein
Boden gestütztes System zur
Luftverteidigung liefern und zwar vier
davon
mithilfe von ihres tslm so der Name
lässt sich über einer Stadt eine Art
Flugverbotszone einrichten bis zu 40 km
weit schützt das System vor Angriffen
mit Flugzeugen Drohnen oder
Kurzstreckenraketen aber ändert das die
Position der Ukraine im Krieg
grundsätzlich
also das System schützt jetzt erstmal
große Ballungszentren und damit in
großen Anteil der Bevölkerung ein
wirklicher gamechanger wie man so oft
sagt würde es dann sein wenn man
deutlich mehr von den Systemen hätte
denn dann könnte man die
offensiv-operation der Ukraine
unterstützen auf der einen Seite und die
Ukraine flächendeckend gegen russische
Angriffe mit Raketen und Flugzeugen
schützen Russland veröffentlicht heute
diese Bilder sie sollen Stärke
demonstrieren doch neue Luftverteidigung
aus Deutschland könnte solche Einsätze
für Piloten bald gefährlicher machen
bulgarien hat ein neues Parlament
gewählt vor wenigen Minuten haben die
Wahllokale geschlossen ersten Trends
zufolge könnte die bürgerliche Partei
des früheren Regierungschefs Boyko
borisoff mit etwa 25% stärkste Kraft
werden weil ihr aber Korruptionen
vorgeworfen wird dürfte die Suche nach
Partnern schwierig werden auf Platz 2
könnten die europa-freundlichen
Liberalen um Kirill Petkov landen dessen
Regierungskoalition im Juni zerbrochen
war
ja und auch Brasilien hat heute die Wahl
wer soll das Land künftig regieren der
frühere oder der aktuelle Präsident
156 Millionen Menschen dürfen abstimmen
laut Umfragen liegt der linke
Ex-Präsident Lula da Silva mit großem
Vorsprung vorn von 2003 bis 2010 hatte
er das Land regiert und fordert jetzt
den rechtspopulistischen Amtsinhaber
bolsonaro heraus der hat angedeutet im
Falle einer Niederlage das Wahlergebnis
anfechten zu wollen
eine Woche vor der Landtagswahl in
Niedersachsen Gerät die AFD unter Druck
nach zdf-informationen ermittelt die
Staatsanwaltschaft Hannover gegen einen
Vorstandsmitglied des Landesverbandes
wegen des Verdachts der Untreue ein
ehemaliger afd-funktionär berichtet von
einer schwarzen Kasse und dem Verkauf
aussichtsreicher Listenplätze da wird
Geppert und Peter Kuntz berichten
Wahlkampf der AFD in Niedersachsen und
der ehemalige stellvertretende
Landesvorsitzende erhebt schwere
Vorwürfe gegen die Partei die er selbst
vor drei Monaten verlassen hat die AFD
so hieß es im austrittsschreiben
entwickle es sich zu einem Sammelbecken
für Versager Gangster Christopher Emden
wird selbst nicht mehr für den Landtag
Niedersachsen kandidieren für einen
sicheren Platz auf der Landesliste so
sagt er hätte er bezahlen müssen ich
kandidieren wollen dann hätte ich mir
Stimmen kaufen müssen und ein Betrag
ungefähr 4.000 Euro war im Gespräch
angesprochen wurde ich von der Stelle
der er eben die kriegsklasse verwaltet
und wohl auch der einzige ist nämlich an
der den Kontozugriff hat Zahlungen um
einen Listenplatz zu bekommen in eine
Kasse über die der heutige
stellvertretende Landesvorsitzende der
AFD möglicherweise frei verfügen kann
Ansgar Schledde überrascht von dem
Vorwürfen ja also kann ich ihnen
überhaupt nicht zu sagen ist
vollkommener Mumpitz höre ich jetzt das
erste mal und
woher kommt das also die
Staatsanwaltschaft Hannover hat nach
Eingang einer Strafanzeige einen
Ermittlungsverfahren wegen des
Anfangsverdachts der Untreue eingeleitet
weitere Auskünfte kann ich gegenwärtig
dazu aber nicht erteilen auch von
niedersächsischen afd-abgeordneten im
Bundestag könnten Gelder auf das dem ZDF
bekannte Konto geflossen sein vielleicht
auch für Hilfe beim Erreichen eines
Listenplatzes die Staatsanwaltschaft
muss klären der Informant klagt er werde
bereits bedroht er hatte die AFD auch
wegen Verrohung verlassen so wie ein
niedersächsischer Kreisverband in einem
Rundbrief Tipps gibt wie man sich in
Krisenzeiten bewaffnen sollte
der US-Bundesstaat Florida kämpft weiter
mit den Folgen von Hurrikan Ian
inzwischen zählen die Behörden etwa 50
Todesopfer tausende Menschen werden aber
noch vermisst in den betroffenen
Gebieten gehen die rettungs- und
Aufräumarbeiten weiter ein Problem sind
immer noch massive Stromausfälle nach
ersten Schätzungen rechnen Versicherer
mit Schäden von etwa 60 Milliarden
Dollar
so jetzt zum Sport und da ist eine
Entscheidung hat ja noch mal vertagt
worden ist nicht vorzeitig Formel 1
Weltmeister geworden dazu hätte er heute
den zunächst ziemlich verregneten Großen
Preis von Singapur gewinnen müssen wurde
am Ende aber nur Siebter den Sieg holte
seinen Red Bull Teamkollege Sergio Perez
zum ersten Mal gewinnt der Mexikaner
dieses Saisonhighlights in der Hitze der
Nacht gelingt dem Red Bull Piloten ein
Start zielsieg Max Verstappen von Rang 8
gestartet im Kampf gegen Länder Norris
um Platz 4 von Position 14 muss er
wieder aufholen immerhin schaffte es
sich auf Rang 7 zurückzukämpfen gegen
Sebastian Vettel der achterwirt
Ferrari-Pilot Charlie Claire holt ein
paar Punkte auf im Kampf um die WM
104 Zähler aber noch der Vorsprung von
Max Verstappen Mick Schumacher kommt als
13 ins Ziel
das erste Sonntagsspiel der
Fußball-Bundesliga zwischen Hertha BSC
und Hoffenheim endete unentschieden eins
zu eins und lässt beide Vereine um einen
Tabellenplatz nach unten rutschen
Hoffenheim jetzt auf fünf härter vorerst
auf 14 eine überraschende 1:3 Niederlage
haben Deutschlands Tischtennisspieler
bei der Mannschafts-WM in China
einstecken müssen gegen Außenseiter
Indien ließen dank you Benedikt duda und
Ricardo Walter zu viele Chancen liegen
und stehen morgen gegen den vermeintlich
stärksten Gruppengegner Frankreich unter
Druck sonst droht den Europameistern
sogar das Vorrunden aus ja und noch 49
Tage bis zum Beginn der Fußball-WM in
Katha und das Objekt der fußballbegierde
hat auf seiner Reise durch die 51
Teilnehmerländer heute auch einen
Zwischenstopp in Berlin gemacht und
diese beiden Herren kennen den Pokal
ziemlich gut Bastian Schweinsteiger und
Lothar Matthäus durften in acht
beziehungsweise 32 Jahre nach dem Titel
gewinnen mal wieder in den Händen halten
ganz zufrieden aus und die Fans dürfen
morgen auch noch mal schauen und
fotografieren aber nicht anfassen dann
vielen Dank Katja so bei uns noch fix
der Blick aufs Wetter in der Nacht gibt
es Regen und 6 bis 14 Grad morgen in der
Mitte und bis zum Erzgebirge dicht
bewölkt sonst erst Nebel dann Sonne bei
12 bis 18 Grad an der Ostsee dabei sehr
windig danach wird es dann überwiegend
trocken sonnig und auch wärmer
Christian Sievers später mit dem
neuesten nachrichtenstand im
heute-journal um 21 Uhr das wars von uns
schönen Abend schönen Feiertag und bis
morgen